[Music]
what's going on here what's new
how much
[Music]
hey TIG have you down there by yourself
out in time just drink it I'm fine I
appreciate it
but it's I'm fine ever since I heard how
I suppose you're wondering why I called
you over here I didn't need to go where
by our basketball coach had a heart
attack the other night they need a new
coach jack then you know you give seem
too many good no the last time they made
the playoffs back when you were playing
you're Marcus right that's right how
many threes in markets make last year
we're percentage of 26 yeah wonder why
they're leaving you open it's because I
don't think you could hit the ocean from
the beach backside shell as bread
[Music]
so I like coaching so far great it's
getting used to the players for players
how much
lyddie
I heard you're coaching basketball yeah
excuse me busy keeps my mind off other
things to him
I spent a lot of time I murdered it
myself bad decision carry other name I
had a lot of regrets
[Music]
Dan's online I want you taking that shot
why is that so hard for you really well
maybe the best player on team
[Music]
really suffering I just want you to be
happy again but you gotta want it too
impressing the traffic taking charges
you guys on this tonight
[Music]